El 28 de febrero un ingeniero en Amazon
cometió un error clave similar, aparentemente pequeño.
Solo digo aparentemente pequeño
porque este pequeño error en el supercódigo de Amazon
produjo una desaceleración masiva de Internet
que costó a la compañía más de USD 160 millones
en el lapso de solo cuatro horas.
Pero esto en realidad es realmente aterrador.
Recientemente un empleado de New England Compound,
que es un fabricante farmacéutico,
no limpió un laboratorio adecuadamente
y ahora 76 personas han muerto
y 700 más han contraído meningitis.
Estos ejemplos son una locura, ¿verdad?
¿Desde cuándo vivimos en un mundo donde se acepta errores tipográficos,
errores comunes que surgen de la actitud de "hacer lo mejor" o "hacer lo suficiente"?
En algún momento, hemos dejado de valorar la perfección,
y ahora, estos son el tipo de resultados que obtenemos.
Creo que todos debemos buscar la perfección,
todo el tiempo,
y creo que tenemos que llegar rápido.
Yo dirijo un centro de formación
de conductores que reparten mercadería,
y en mi trabajo,
tenemos una perspectiva única del costo de los fallos,
el costo de solo el 99 %,
porque en el mundo de la conducción profesional,
hacer solo el 99 % del trabajo implica que alguien muere.
Cien personas mueren todos los días
por choques con vehículos.
Piensen en eso un segundo.
Eso equivale a cuatro aviones comerciales
que chocan cada semana,
pero aun así no nos convencemos de prestar perfecta atención al volante.
Por eso enseño a mis conductores a valorar la perfección.
Es por eso que les hago memorizar
nuestro programa de manejo defensivo de 131 palabras
perfectamente,
y luego les hago reescribirlas.
Una palabra incorrecta, mal escrita, una coma faltante, es una prueba fallida.
Es por eso que hago inspecciones de uniformes a diario.
Las camisetas son blancas o marrones solamente,
los zapatos son de cuero negro o marrón pulido
y no lleguen con mal aspecto a mi clase y esperen que les deje quedar.
Por eso insisto en que mis conductores lleguen a tiempo.
No lleguen tarde a clase, al descanso, al almuerzo.
Cuando se supone que debes estar en algún lugar, debes estar ahí.
Hago esto para que mis alumnos entiendan
que cuando los entreno para conducir un auto y digo
"Limpien cada intersección"
entiendan que me refiero a cada señal de tráfico, a cada cruce de calles,
cada calle lateral, cada estacionamiento, cada camino de tierra,
cada paso de peatones, cada intersección, sin falla.
Los nuevos estudiantes a menudo me preguntan
por qué mi clase es tan difícil, estricta o uniforme,
y la respuesta es simple.
El perfeccionismo es una actitud desarrollada en las cosas pequeñas
y luego se aplica al trabajo más grande.
Y, básicamente, si no puedes hacer las cosas bien,
vas a fallar cuando sea importante,
y cuando conduces un automóvil, cuenta.
Un automóvil que viaja a 90 km por hora
cubre la longitud de un campo de fútbol americano
en poco menos de cuatro segundos y medio,
pero es la misma cantidad de tiempo
que necesita una persona promedio para revisar un mensaje de texto.
Así que no permito que mis conductores pierdan el foco,
y no acepto nada menos que la perfección de ellos.
¿Y saben?
Estoy cansado de que todos acepten el 99 % como lo suficientemente bueno.
Quiero decir, ser menos que perfecto tiene consecuencias reales, ¿no?
Piénsenlo.
Si los creadores de tarjetas de crédito tuvieran solo un 99,9 % de efectividad,
habría más de un millón de tarjetas en circulación hoy
con información incorrecta en la banda magnética en la parte posterior.
O, si el diccionario Webster fuera solo un 99,9 % exacto,
contendría 470 palabras mal escritas.
¿Qué tal esto?
Si nuestros médicos solo tuvieran un 99,9 % de respuestas correctas,
cada año se escribirían incorrectamente 4 453 000 de recetas
y probablemente aún más aterrador,
11 recién nacidos se entregarían a los padres equivocados
todos los días en EE.UU.
(Risas)
Y esas son solo las probabilidades, gracias.
La realidad es que el gobierno de EE.UU. estrelló un avión de USD 1400 millones
porque el equipo de mantenimiento solo hizo el 99 % de su trabajo.
Alguien olvidó revisar un sensor.
La realidad es que 16 personas ahora están muertas,
180 sufrieron heridas,
y 34 millones de autos han sido retirados del mercado
porque fabricantes de un airbag de auto produjeron y distribuyeron un producto
que pensaban que era lo suficientemente bueno.
La realidad es que los errores médicos
ahora son la tercera causa de muerte en EE.UU.
250 000 personas mueren cada año
porque alguien que, quizá, pensó que hacía su trabajo suficientemente bien
provocó un desastre.
¿Y no me creen?
Ciertamente puedo entender por qué.
Es difícil para nosotros creer algo en estos días
cuando menos del 50 % de lo que opinan los expertos
en realidad está basado en hechos.
(Risas)
Y todo se reduce a esto:
dar lo mejor de nosotros no es lo suficientemente bueno.
Y ¿cómo cambiamos?
Buscamos la perfección
y no nos conformamos con nada menos.
Quiero darles un minuto para pensar sobre eso,
porque sé lo que les han dicho.
Quizá algo así como, la perfección es imposible para los humanos,
por lo tanto, buscar la perfección no solo arruinará su autoestima
sino que será un fracaso.
Pero esa es la ironía.
Hoy todos tememos tanto el fracaso de la palabra,
pero la verdad es que tenemos que fracasar.
El fracaso es un trampolín natural hacia la perfección,
pero en algún momento, tuvimos tanto miedo a esa idea de fracaso
y estuvimos tan asustados ante esa idea de perfección,
que la descartamos por temor a lo que sucedería con nuestro ego
al fallar.
Quiero decir, ¿de verdad creen que el fracaso les va a arruinar?
¿O es solo la respuesta fácil la que nos da sitios web lentos,
un cuidado de la salud aterrador y carreteras peligrosas?
Quiero decir, ¿están listos para perfeccionar lo malo en todo esto?
El fracaso y la imperfección son básicamente lo mismo.
Todos sabemos que la imperfección existe a nuestro alrededor.
Nada y nadie es perfecto.
Pero en algún momento, porque era demasiado difícil o doloroso,
decidimos descartar nuestra capacidad natural para hacer frente a la falla
y lo reemplazamos por un nivel de aceptación inferior.
Y ahora todos estamos obligados a recostarnos
y a aceptar solo esta nueva norma o actitud suficientemente buena
y el resultado que eso trae aparejado.
Incluso con todo lo dicho,
la gente todavía me dirá,
"El personal médico, el equipo de mantenimiento, el ingeniero,
¿no hicieron todo lo posible, y no es lo suficientemente bueno?"
A decir verdad, no para mí y especialmente no en estos ejemplos.
Sí, pero tratar de ser perfecto es muy estresante, ¿verdad?
Y, Oprah habló sobre eso, las universidades lo estudian,
seguro que el consejero de su escuela les advirtió al respecto.
El estrés es malo para nosotros, ¿no es así?
Quizás,
pero decir que buscar la perfección es demasiado estresante
es como decir que el ejercicio es demasiado agotador.
En ambos casos, si quieres resultados, debes soportar el dolor.
Y, sinceramente, decir que buscar la perfección es demasiado estresante
es solo una excusa para ser flojo.
Pero aquí está la parte realmente aterradora.
Hoy médicos, terapeutas
y la industria de autoayuda de casi USD 10 000 millones al año
todos defienden la idea de la perfección
bajo esta apariencia de no intentar ser perfecto
salvará tu autoestima y protegerá tu ego.
Pero no está funcionando,
porque la industria de autoayuda tiene una mayor tasa de reincidencia
porque está más centrada en enseñarte a aceptar un fracaso
y bajar el nivel de aceptación,
que en tratar de alentarte a ser perfecto.
Estos médicos, terapeutas y gurús de autoayuda
todos se enfocan en un síntoma y no en la enfermedad.
La verdadera enfermedad en la sociedad es la falta de voluntad
para enfrentar el fracaso.
Nos sentimos más cómodos descansando en nuestros esfuerzos
de lo que somos al enfocarnos en nuestros resultados.
Como en la secundaria Dublin Jerome en Ohio,
donde nombran mejores estudiantes al 30 % de una clase de graduación.
Vamos, por favor ¿no?
Alguien tenía las notas más altas.
Les garantizo que no fue un empate múltiple de 72 personas.
(Risas)
Pero nos sentimos más cómodos ofreciendo un resultado igual
de lo que somos al enfrentar el fracaso, el perdedor o el que no alcanza.
Y cuando todos obtienen un premio, todos avanzan,
o todos reciben un aumento salarial a pesar de los resultados,
el perfeccionista que llevamos dentro se pregunta:
¿Qué tengo que hacer para mejorar?
¿Cómo sobresalgo entre la multitud?
Y si seguimos cultivando esta cultura,
donde nadie falla o nadie dice que van a fallar,
entonces nadie va a alcanzar su potencial tampoco.
El fracaso y la pérdida son necesarios para el éxito.
La aceptación del fracaso no lo es.
Se le atribuye a Miguel Ángel haber dicho
que el mayor peligro para la mayoría
no es que nuestro objetivo sea demasiado alto y no lo logremos,
sino que sea demasiado bajo y lo alcancemos.
El fracaso debe ser una fuerza motivadora,
no un tipo de excusa patética para rendirse.
Por eso, tengo una idea.
En vez de definir el perfeccionismo como intolerancia destructiva para el fracaso,
¿por qué no intentar darle una nueva definición?
¿Por qué no definir el perfeccionismo como la disposición
a hacer lo que es difícil y lograr lo que es correcto?
Podemos estar de acuerdo
en que el fracaso es algo bueno en nuestra búsqueda de la perfección,
y cuando buscamos la perfección sin miedo al fracaso,
solo piensen en lo que podemos lograr.
Como la superestrella de la NBA Steph Curry:
bateó 77 tiros de tres puntos seguidos.
Piénsenlo.
El pudo lanzar con precisión una pelota de 24 cm
a una canasta de 45 cm suspendida a 3 m de altura
desde unos 7 m de distancia
casi 80 veces sin fallar.
O como los programadores de computadoras
del gigante aeroespacial Lockheed Martin,
que han escrito un programa
que usa 420 000 líneas de código casi perfecto
para controlar todos los aspectos
de la combustión de 2 millones de kg de combustible para cohetes
y poner una nave espacial de 120 toneladas en órbita.
O tal vez como los investigadores
en el Children's Mercy Hospital en Kansas City, Missouri,
que han desarrollado un dispositivo
que puede completar la codificación del genoma humano en solo 26 horas.
Y este dispositivo puede diagnosticar enfermedades genéticas
en bebés y recién nacidos,
dando a los médicos la oportunidad de comenzar los tratamientos antes
y potencialmente salvar la vida del bebé.
Eso es lo que sucede cuando buscamos la perfección.
Así que tal vez deberíamos ser más como el atleta profesional,
o deberíamos ser más como ese incansable programador,
o como ese investigador apasionado.
Entonces, podríamos dejar de temer al fracaso
y podríamos dejar de vivir en un mundo lleno de consecuencias
de lo suficientemente bueno.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)